[Music]
in crazy love news [ __ ] submitted by
my name is jeff fiffie a man who was
stabbed 13 times by his girlfriend
proposes to her in court she collects
the berries out of his ass she's cool
man would you marry this girl do you
know that she eats my ass 24 hours a day
you'll find me a woman that'll do that
human centipedes yep 23rd is the truth I
like scary movies and oh yeah there's a
lot of unanswered question Oh some
Japanese guy you like anyway I would
just add my dogs that he did it yeah
that was like the humans however yeah
all right I like dogs a lot anybody
hurts dog this chick's definitely doing
something he just thank you [ __ ]
in fact crazy busy he's like worth it's
worth it that's worth all this he [ __ ]
up he cheated and he's like I deserve it
I did that's true so this takes place in
Russia
vodka is a contributors you only spend
13 times why would they leave right last
girlfriend if I'm alive why leave stupid
they have girlfriend I'm not trying to
please dude's name is Shakur isn't it
just [ __ ] - Fox cousin I know for
sure I'm cousin yes in the Vepr I was
trying to prove I was invincible yeah I
win she proved me right yes
got into this big fight I don't know
about what I didn't say about what oh
yeah this was not their first fight oh
for sure for sure he's been stabbed
seven times I pick up after himself he
left the socks on the floor again he's
like honestly it was my fault yeah the
dishwasher completely seven thirteen
times he managed to get away from her
and that's how he was able to survive go
find the ring to go buy medical health
ring and then so he needed three weeks
of hospital treatment weeks of course
she did I don't know but you know he's
texting her that afternoon he's like
yeah we're okay so he was during her
like when she was in courts and he was
pleading to the judge for leniency
because they wanted to arrange the date
of their wedding cuz he proposed to her
okay you know this [ __ ] happens the
other way too there's dudes and like
chicks get the same way oh yeah they
beat the crap out of their cause
battered syndrome or something what a
turd housewive or something yeah we are
super strange species yeah that's what I
want a farm there's no other animal that
this would ever take place with you
can't like stab your dog a bunch and
that dogs ever cool with you again yeah
what the [ __ ] are you man I actually
think dogs will still stay cool with you
thank you yeah have you stabbed it you
get a dog that's like Ben and a pound
and like rescue a dog that was abused
they're not cool I love fun but
sometimes spawn hurts my feelings dude
because I've been around for quite a
long time and every time she's like
[ __ ] fun so you [ __ ] [ __ ] how
many guys have you seen one of my dogs
will like come up and beg for snacks and
then when I go to give him a snack she
looks at me and she's like like all
suspect I'm like [ __ ] I've never
handed you something that you weren't
into and you've been begging for a thing
and then I hit him - you're like
she's mr. Paul roundish bingos even if
it's just like a potato chip she'll just
run off with it yeah because she's
showing your other dog
Luke who's the [ __ ] boss I'm gonna
make this for my [ __ ] and then you go
get it you actually watch so she goes
yes things have [ __ ] changed in my
house like how did the dog show me a
middle finger with its paws somehow did
it just a little like that
Ziggy's in trouble it's the equivalent
of a cat just putting their [ __ ] at
you there you go stole a bag of you know
those like cheeto Chex Mix oh yeah yeah
yeah stole the whole thing and then ate
it all but left all the pretzels go
through their food leave it's like a mix
kibble and eat the ones they want that
[ __ ] yeah I talked to do that too
I'm not dr. Lee your vegetables like if
we give them like leftover food they'll
leave all the vegetables our dogs will
hammer like broccoli stalks
yeah broccoli though eat your carrots
carrots what let's get new pictures yeah
no not dogs like carrots yeah you've got
to give their eyesight back crazy so
this woman faces up to six years before
the [ __ ] yeah
she completed guilty why she denied that
she had intended to kill her boyfriend
she was drunk that time did not intend I
didn't want to kill him is it show him
off is that his haircut yeah and
deserves every [ __ ] minute of this
looks like a Neanderthal look at that
haircut oh my god yeah that's how you
help fast he looks fast haircut dude
when it's pronounced me under Paul how
much I bet he's silent Mike in the
[ __ ]
two new dollars it is I'm coming up he's
actually right it is me Android Paul
Neanderthal where do they come up with
all that we've been saying it wrong the
whole time just throwing H's in there
for no reason it's like cool I'm gonna
Porsche yeah looks like a Russian Joe
Dirt or something he doesn't have a jet
ski in his driveway no it's nowhere near
water
I got a jet ski he's kind of like a
little hideous so I understand he's
never gonna find another what does he do
for a living I know it isn't scientists
I think what he does he smashes
sandwiches in his face for the best [ __ ]
I don't know what the final knife
Chester nice brother
what's problem what's problem steps
babies what'd I do
it's no big deal was blood I just did
this morning with sister what I asked
her stem it was accident it's how we
have sex okay we just hide knives in the
bed did you guys ever know like crazy
ask couples like when you were younger
or whenever that they would get you
there you guys were in those like the
craziest fights but then they would have
like the craziest make up yeah like wild
I think a lot of people have a lot of
great makeup sex they laughter they
fight furiously
yeah then what's the point of fighting I
knew I knew a couple that the girl
wanted to break up with the dude and so
the dudes I well if I can't have you
we're gonna die together crash into a
light post so she's like you're [ __ ]
crazy and he was driving her car she's
like you're [ __ ] crazy we're gonna
break up they broke up in a week later
they're back together again
and that's just on and off crazy [ __ ] I
see [ __ ] like that on high school like
all our friends were like that in high
school yeah I just hated when the guy
when the guy or the girl was so adamant
about how much of a piece of [ __ ] that
person is and me I back up French to the
[ __ ] max so I'm over here talking man
I'm like you know I never [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] gap-toothed [ __ ] anyways
then they get together the next day yeah
I'm a yo man about what I said about her
she's dope bro but something about her
teeth man she's gotta breathe
that's why you should choose on rocks
yeah I just like not say anything now
and you just let it play out because you
can't just be in that situation it just
sucks cuz you got a look at her [ __ ]
gap-toothed all day meanwhile your
friends stupid yeah that's what you
learned from the we warned him not to go
back and then I remember this one guy he
was like he's like he what he would
always be complaining about how shitty
his girlfriend was or whatever and like
and then everyone was like just don't go
back don't go back and then he gets back
but not only does he get back with her
he turns around and says they don't
understand us and they've been talking
[ __ ] about you oh oh only talking [ __ ]
because he's been telling us all the
negative [ __ ] worst type of dude ever
it's like what do you think we got the
[ __ ] information from dude like what
the he all of a sudden [ __ ] forgets
all the [ __ ] that he was talking
he's like my friends I don't listen to
them they got a real [ __ ] yeah he
deserves me fought by his friends I know
I'm like [ __ ] that dude it was all we
got a young made you make all those
stupid oh yeah your brain doesn't
[ __ ] work then hyper [ __ ] it
emotionally she brain doesn't work in
high school yeah you the only reason why
I know so many Brightman nice songs
because I got dumped once and then
though she's [ __ ] over here playing
keys I gotta [ __ ] Ray Charles in my
room you see it crying did you ever cry
to a song in like when the songs done
you take a break from crying and then
you replay it and you start again you
ever know yeah she was slow I mean cut
him off
[ __ ] leave her real quick I'm saving
my love for Bart shut the [ __ ] up you
giant but you're gigantism yeah I guess
well you're gonna die aren't you guys
your hearts gonna fall right aren't you
guys the same height that you wanna
admit I know but I've seen her make
pizza dough in two seconds is amazing
wait wait so wait he proposed to her in
the courtroom yeah and then watch a
movie did he get all any daddy asked the
judge - oh yeah marriage right there
Your Honor woo is the question did they
ask the judge so just be the hook
administer right there what about people
that [ __ ] like will marry a dude who's
in jail forever I know you're not
married when he was in jail Charles of
his newer stuff only though he had a lot
of ladies over his whole county they get
conjugal visits and stuff depends on the
prison Charles made like did not he's
gonna eat her what ring was this was a
penis if this was a [ __ ]
it was inching closer to each other
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]